debate club yeah let's move on they were
good though
those guys a great man and here's this
guy dude house you've been doing drugs
at home bro
you only know that because I'm dumb and
that's how I look also this [ __ ]
ain't gonna last another 30 days to Korn
a bar gets you really lost himself
Royce Cole did one movie the Amy Schumer
nice lost his [ __ ] money it's Jordan
out here in Denver Colorado sure it is
we're quarantined working from home
lucky to have that option amen brother
not lucky to not have cut my hair right
before hand cuz barber shops are closed
up for another four weeks so I don't
know what I'm gonna do about this
situation but it's my new normal until
April 30th so in the meantime I got a
debate club question for you better
documentary tiger King or making a
murderer let me know what you guys think
shout out Nick Davis LT Darsh Gang Gang
buzzbuzz buzzbuzz
5280 Club right there baby I'm hometown
sweetie man I'm gonna go with making a
murderer
I think Tiger king hit at the exact time
or in quarantine it's good but if you
going back watch a second time oh yeah
be honest I'm sick of these [ __ ]
Tiger thirst traps man these altmer
fuck-ups oh my mom's sake everybody jump
on their nuts I was on their nuts last
we come off now I can't stand Tigers I
don't play with you Tigers make it
emerge some real [ __ ] bro make a noise
[ __ ] the guy [ __ ] killed a woman that
took pictures of vehicles dude I
wouldn't call it some real [ __ ] okay
what do you think Tiger King is Tiger
King is a homosexual Clint Eastwood okay
who has one working leg and the other is
a dick with an e on it yeah because he
shot himself in the leg okay you know
mainly it is to tell everybody to look
everybody in the eyes and then shoot
yourself in your own [ __ ] leg to
prove a point time and time again dude I
would say enjoy it thanks dude hey not
even gone dude do nothing
how crazy bro just the level of just
constant just turmoil you've set up in
your own life you wake up you have to
deal with forty sixty seventy eight
eighty Tigers or snipers or a bucket or
three you're having Tiger for lunch
brothers so many [ __ ] if you don't
stress
yeah and then I go no to go into a gift
shop and comfortably sell a hat or a Joe
exotic sponge or somebody your employee
got their arm ripped I didn't get a full
refund you know go through all that then
finally you get home and you have two
husbands and either the only the only
thing they cooked for dinner is drugs
and you gotta go to then you go do an
episode of Joe exotic TV wake up do it
all again the next day I do a podcast at
6 p.m. oh that [ __ ] you just went
through yeah he's a Leonardo DiCaprio on
the second Vince in the one side piece
that he's really gay every day I Spit
game on him cuz he wants chicks you
reading books to me you've subbed out
all the words and put in gay of
commitment that Joe exotic had no his on
my question is work ethic okay I'm not
doing that okay I'm not doing that is
that's what I'm worried about you're
doing no I'm not doing that his work
ethic is second to none
that gets an on second to none you see
him in all the videos he's helping load
this load this cat [ __ ] I'm saying put
this load of somebody's ass somebody
that's all he's always trying to do is
load some boys asses up dude I'm not
buying it man I'm sick of joy exactly
how about [ __ ] Joe I'm not freeing that
you should do all 22 years man killing
all them [ __ ] Tigers damn off the
train bro [ __ ] tiger on my face
wow man i man who so what training you
on then you're on the train of a guy who
went to jail for murder got out and then
murdered somebody else dude you're in
the jail for Steve
in Avery I better show I just think
making a murderer is more quality as far
as a documentary I think Dan Hernandez
one was better I think Joe exotic kid at
the right [ __ ] time well I agree
people are awesome there's nothing to do
worked cage that we are caged animals
right now so I think people can relate
on an innate level but I guess good and
you got it you got some find it on the
inner and then you find out he's not
really singing them songs don't think
what's what's real was he really gay
always question is gayness do you've
always seen those songs I do know now
that he did not sing the songs but I'm
not shocked he didn't because he was
lip-syncing the entire time it's
blatantly obviously was losing why do
you know how some people he sang it is
non gay husband's funeral dude he's on
meth huh these are methods yeah sit
still well imagine doing all of that and
having to do math dude yeah and then
also manage four hundred Tigers yeah I
cannot get what you're saying you give a
good argument man I'm saying for my
money you seen the devil next door oh
dude you start living bro [ __ ] to do go
on Netflix and watch a devil next door
about a Nazi concentration camp guy he's
the main one Ivan the Terrible put all
the Jews in the [ __ ] gas chamber
horrible man yep and then they [ __ ]
find him they found out he's living in
Cleveland and they [ __ ] deport his
ass back to Israel he goes on Rio goes
on trial did he do it is it definitely
him
well I don't spoil you they 23andme
no way Wow Ivan the Terrible
that shit's more real than he's [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] about the Tigers this
goes back to the poll that Theo threw
out last week is Joe exotic actually gay
people say 38% think it's drug-induced
homosexuality amen
what's the rest think 62% are ignorant
you don't have a mullet and then grow up
the roots with a blonde and that's ugh
dick that boy is so gay
well but here's the thing you do enough
drugs you're gay man I grew up by a bob
behind a rest area like across a river
from a rest area sure and a lot of gay
men used to meet up along side of the
interstate mysterious yeah still do and
they were fine everybody was fine they'd
show up with their families at first and
stuff and then the families would leave
drugs would come then the men were gay
so it was like a progression Airy thing
you've seen it in the seen probably shop
Tina I bet 110 times so you have a good
case study bro its facts man so at a
certain point it's fact so I'm saying
nobody's gay until enough drugs is in
the scene and then everybody's gay
you're gonna attic you do anything to
get that hit again yeah you know if you
tell somebody you know hey I hit a
little bit of meth in my wiener you know
get it out yeah there's only one way to
get out yeah so you gotta it's magic bro
it's just a certain type of magic
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]